[Music]
umbrella academy fans look no further
we've collected the absolute best fan
theories about the show if you want to
know who created the Commission the real
reason for Vanya's breakdown and where
the other 36 siblings may be take a look
here are the Umbrella Academy theories
that are so crazy they just might be
true watch to the end to find out how
Ben died but who killed him who did this
I have a crazy idea crazy what do the
numbers mean reddit is bubbling with
questions and theories about the method
Reginald used to number the children he
acquired many fans assumed that Reginald
just numbered the children in the order
in which he acquired them but what if
there is more significance to the
numbers one redditor pointed out that in
the comics the numbers are shown as
decimal points this person thought that
maybe the numbers were based on the time
they were born but weren't they all born
simultaneously all over the world
another theory is that the numbers are
based on the usefulness royalty and
temperament of the children it could
also be a way to rank them in terms of
how powerful they are
in that case number seven would be the
most powerful and number one would be
the least powerful if you think about it
that kind of makes sense let's look at
each character and rank their skills and
powers to see if this adds up first
we've got number one Luther Luther is
definitely the most loyal to his father
out of the bunch he tries to be a good
leader
but usually falls short with his
leadership skills that might have
something to do with the fact that he
just spent four years on the moon Luther
has super strength and incredible
durability but he seems to be a bit
lacking in the smarts and wisdom
Department so it would make sense that
Reginald would rank him as the least
powerful sibling last time check I'm
still the leader of this family number
two
Diego Diego has amazing knife-throwing
and combat fighting skills his dance
moves are pretty sick too Diego has the
ability to throw any object with
pinpoint accuracy he can manipulate the
objects he throws to make them curve in
midair in order to hit their targets
that's a pretty useful skill however
Diego has a major chip on his shoulder
he has trouble trusting anyone except
for detective patch he
is likely a tough nut to crack growing
up so reginal ranked him as second least
powerful let's just say I didn't get a
good look at their faces
number three Alison Alison has a very
interesting power she has the ability to
control a person's behavior by
whispering I heard a rumor followed by
whatever action she wants them to take
while this is a pretty handy skill it's
not quite as impressive as speaking to
the deceased or jumping through time
Alison has been of it selfish in the
past it seems she has abused her powers
to turn herself into a famous actress
this must have caused some major trouble
for her because her personal life is
kind of a mess we're dying to know if
her daughter has powers too still it
seems reginal ranked her as average when
it comes to her powers and weaknesses we
need the full force of the Academy to
even stand a chance
number 4 claws claws quickly became a
fan favorite for his eccentric style and
vulnerability which is thinly veiled
with a dry witty sense of humor but
Clauses Power has caused some major
addiction problems in his life it's got
to be hard to cope when they're being
followed around by ghosts all day and
night Klaus is volatile and impulsive
which must have made him difficult to
control still there's no denying that
she has an incredible gift and from what
we gather from the season finale we are
just beginning to scratch the surface of
what you can do now that he's sober
still reginal saw fit to rank him at
number 4 really awful terrible
depressing times number 5 it's unclear
why 5 was never given a name it seems
that their robot mother grace gave all
the other siblings their names so why
didn't she give 5 a name we suspect we
will definitely find out more about that
in the next season fives powers are
incredibly powerful he has the ability
to jump through time and space but he
doesn't seem to have full control over
this power he got stuck in the
post-apocalyptic future for a really
long time for some reason he couldn't
use his powers to go back in time from
that point he also appears to get tired
quickly when he was running from hazel
and chacha in the department store he
started losing his ability to jump to
different spaces the longer the chase
went on still it's clear that he has a
very special gift so he is number 5
just like that yeah number six
Ben then has the ability to shoot
powerful deadly tentacles from his chest
to eliminate his enemies but when he was
a boy he seemed very troubled by the
destruction he was capable of with his
power it's clear that Ben died sometime
in his young adult life but we still
don't know how we can only see him
through claws who often sees and talks
with his deceased brother Ben must have
been very powerful while he was alive
that has to be the reason reginal ranked
him so high if that was his method are
you talk in your sleep
and finally number 7 Vanya Vanya is
incredible telekinetic abilities make
her the most powerful member of the
Umbrella Academy as a child she was so
powerful Reginald locked her away and
convinced her that she had no powers he
used Alison to convince her that she was
just ordinary nothing special but all
that isolation and alienation has given
her some major psychological issues
she's got some work to do before she can
safely use her powers again after that
whole moon incident after examining all
the Umbrella Academy members it stands
to reason that Reginald did rank them
from least to most powerful but what do
you think the other siblings in the
story 42 babies are born spontaneously
on the same day two women who had not
previously been pregnant reginal adopts
seven of those babies but many people
are asking what happened to the other 36
children did they perish in the
apocalyptic explosion that Vanya cost
when showrunners steve blackman and
comics Arthur Gerard Way were asked if
we would be seen any of the other 36
siblings they were quite secretive they
replied that while that was a really
good question they couldn't answer it
there is a scene toward the end of the
first season that might have some clues
about the 43 babies there's a flashback
scene in which a young Reginald
Hargreaves sits at his wife's bedside
while she lies there dying it doesn't
look like there in his mansion but some
other palace like place with flowing
curtains and a round window according to
the comics Reginald is actually an alien
so maybe we're seeing him and
home planet so what are those little
golden lights he releases from the jar
are actually the Unreal Academy children
maybe they are migrating from his home
planet to planet Earth in order to
fulfill a mission so could those
spontaneous births he alien induced
pregnancies we've got another theory
that beats that one maybe the six
siblings become fetuses inside women's
bellies when they time jump we know that
five became significantly younger when
he jumped back to the present time
perhaps the six siblings have to keep
jumping back in time to be reborn and
try to stop the apocalypse from
occurring that would mean they went back
six times to try and get it right if you
do the math six siblings multiplied six
times equals 36 which is the amount
remaining from the original 43 and since
then is already deceased he would be
able to jump through time to be reborn
so maybe those other 36 babies are
Luther Diego Allison Clause 5 and Vanya
being reborn six times that could be the
reason grace didn't give five a name
maybe she's just keeping track of how
many times he has been reborn now our
heads are spinning time travel is
confusing you guys did Reginald cause
the apocalypse one Reddit user has a
theory that it wasn't Vanya who was the
true cause of the apocalypse
this user believes that Reginald
Hargreaves set off a chain of events
that eventually led to the destruction
of the moon and the earth if you think
about it Reginald is responsible for
alienated Vanya from the rest of her
siblings he saw how strong and
potentially catastrophic her powers were
and decided it would be best if she
believed she was ordinary he told her
repeatedly that she was not special he
wouldn't even let her get a matching
umbrella tattoo with the rest of her
brothers and sister she wanted so badly
to be included so she drew her tattoo on
using a marker poor Vanya so if Reginald
had been a more nurturing provider who
taught Vanya restraint where things have
gone differently Vanya has got some
serious emotional heartache from her
childhood that leads to her cataclysmic
meltdown at the end of season one he
can't help but wonder what she would
have been capable of if she had grown up
with a happy childhood and a loving
father maybe she wouldn't have blown
that chunk off the moon and destroyed
her childhood home
control vanya personality disorder some
fans have speculated that Vanya has some
sort of mental disassociation when van
believes it might be borderline
personality disorder so maybe those
pills were actually psychiatric
medication prescribed to control her
brainwaves according to Mayo Clinic
borderline personality disorder is a
mental health disorder that impacts the
way a person thinks and feels about
themselves and others this disorder can
cause problems with functioning and
everyday life there is usually a pattern
of unstable intense relationships this
certainly explains her hookup with
Leonora Peabody the disorders also
characterized by distorted self-image
extreme emotions and impulsiveness Vanya
does struggle with all of those things
in the show her powers seem to be
connected to her emotions so it makes
sense that those pills would suppress
her powers as they suppress her
emotional outbursts one fan went two
step further in diagnosing Vanya this
fan believes she is a sociopath he
points out an interesting pattern from
her childhood
Vanya's asked to eat oatmeal by grace or
mom and soon since her flying into a
glass cabinet but mom stands up fixes
her busted neck and asks again Vanya
doesn't seem to have any feelings about
any of this she just seems a little
stunned when grey stand up and fixes her
neck good observation void bear that's
definitely some sociopathic behavior
coming from little Vanya Reginald
theories so if you follow the comic
books you'll know that Reginald's
monocle allowed him to perceive certain
things so there's a good chance that
when he looked at the moon he saw that
it was destined to explode and maybe
this planet has a connection with earth
in that it's survival is directly linked
to Earth's existence
so in Vanya blows up the moon and
subsequently the earth
maybe hargreaves his home planet is also
doomed so he could have sent Luther to
the moon to collect data to learn what
could keep it from exploding although
that theory doesn't really explain why
all those packages from Luther were left
unopened another awesome reginal theory
is that he is the one who started the
commission that seems like something
Reginald would do but one van theory has
our minds completely blown
editor uma Kalu posted that reginald is
actually number five that would mean
that number five is the one who started
the commission maybe he is the one who
created all those time travel suitcases
he could have somehow injected his
powers into the suitcases when he
started the commission how did Ben die
everyone is obsessed with the
circumstances around Ben's death in the
show the comic book series hasn't
revealed how Ben dies so it remains one
of the biggest umbrella academy
mysteries all we know is that it is
really gruesome and it caused the
breakup of the Academy we know that he
has the ability to channel monsters from
other dimensions so maybe he channeled a
monster that overpowered him resulting
in his death another theory is that he
took his own life he seemed very
tormented when he had to attack those
bank-robbers with those giant monster
tentacles maybe it was too much for him
he could have perished in the apocalypse
somehow whatever the reason we hope it's
revealed in season 2 what are some of
your best umbrella academy theories drop
them in the comments thanks for watching
the things be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to be the first
to see our newest videos we hope you
liked this video and if you did please
click the thumbs up button see you next
time
[Music]